oh
let's start talking our last but not the
least Focus today
um
so today we'll talk about low end
navigation and learning this is a joint
work with the lead Boyle evalon Roberts
and Pierre
so first of all what is program
obfuscation what is the intuitive goal
behind program obfuscation so we want to
hide the implementation of a program
while preserving the functionality so
here you can see an example that I took
from the internet about some program you
can try to guess what the program was
before this happened to it
um yeah so it just
some website from the internet it
obviously it comes with no
um guarantees whatsoever but this is the
original program just computes the
Fibonacci numbers
I also tried to use GPT and ask it to
obfuscate the program but it really
didn't work it gave me something that is
just wrong it outputs numbers that are
not the Fibonacci numbers
and I'm not sure if it's that obfuscated
strong in both ways both ways
[Music]
so obviously you need to preserve
functionality okay
you just didn't interpret it in the
right programming language
reinterpret all the symbols yeah
and we can change the definition so yeah
because we love it so much
yeah okay so ideally what we want some
notion of virtual black box of the
station that is we don't want the office
scale code to reveal more information
than a black box access
unfortunately this notion doesn't exist
it's impossible to obtain virtual blacks
black box obfuscation as proven
my paper like pretty old one from 2001
and it led to coming up with a few
various Notions of obfuscation and the
most common one in the literature is
indistinguishability obfuscation
and the overall or the informal
definition of in distinguishability
obfuscation is a polynomial
probabilistic polynomial time algorithm
such that for every
um two pairs of programs the computes
the same thing they're functionally
equivalent and of the same size we have
the distribution of the i o and the
first circuit is indistinguishable from
the i o and the second circuit and here
I didn't specify two things right I
didn't tell you what program means and I
didn't tell you what indistinishability
means all right so we will build it
um
now so here on the y-axis you can see
different Notions of programs right we
can have decision trees we can have
three cnfs and of course we can have the
most General notion of Boolean circuits
and we can have on the x-axis we have
different Notions of
indistinguishability we have
computational indistinguishability we
have statistical and perfect and I will
go over it
soon here
um yeah okay so the standard notion of
indistinguishability obfuscation and
literature usually refers to kind of
mostly refers to computational
obfuscation of Boolean circuits okay so
this is where
um it stands so let's see what is the
definition of computational
instinishability
so essentially what it means okay so I I
included all kinds of crypto definitions
here because I assume the cryptographers
will not be here because I have a
deadline today but I have been told that
the deadline passed so I don't know
maybe they did arrive
D half an hour ago half an hour okay
yeah so my joke doesn't work anymore but
that's okay
okay so two ensembles of distributions
are um
let's start with computationally
indistinguishable if every polynomial
size circus family cannot distinguish
between the distribution and the
advantage and the distinguishing
advantages negligible and in the notion
of statistical indistinguishability is
the same except here we don't limit the
size of the Circuit Family the
distinguishers
and perfect indistinguishability means
just that the field distributions are
the same
okay so this notion of inducing civilian
obfuscation has many applications in the
literature starting from deniable
encryption optimal multi-parity
computation
hardness of finding Nash equilibrium and
also in this Workshop it has been
mentioned in different contexts so we
heard about IO and its application
has has a lot of application this is a
partial list
okay so a natural question is does
computational i o exist
the first
if you're an algorithm kind if P equals
NP then yes it's very simple to
construct obfuscation we just pick you
give me a circuit I'm just going to pick
the lexical graphically first equivalent
program for circuit right if P equals
NPI can do it and it's very easy
and in heuristica does IO exist and the
answer is no this is a work by money and
others that show that if
um
NP is not infinitely often BPP and IO
exist and we can construct one-way
function
okay and this argument also rules out
pestiland right the existence of ion
Percy land
okay and what happens in minicrypt is
the answer is also no because if you
give me an i o and one-way function we
can construct public key encryption in
fact even in this talk later today I
will show similar ideas about how to
construct a public encryption
and in crypto Mania plus plus probably
yes we have good evidence that it exists
there are recent uh works from 2001 in
2002 that constructed uh obfuscation for
General circuits using well studied
computational assumptions
okay and now does statistical IO exist
and probably not here okay so here what
happens is that above this line deciding
equivalence of programs is co-np hard
okay and if you're in this area then
unless the polynomial hierarchy
collapses we cannot do statistical
obfuscation and the idea is that we can
use the randomness of the i o of the
short proof of equivalence of programs
so if you're here and equivalence is
going to be hard we cannot do
statistical obfuscation
and our work is here in this area so
we're going to talk about statistical
obfuscation for weak models in the sense
that we can test equivalence quickly and
we will also talk about notion of
computational
obfuscation for simple program classes
like cn3 CNF that we cannot hope to get
um
statistical i o for three CNF but we
will still ask if they're simple in some
sense and I will Define soon uh
computational obfuscation for three cnns
okay
so
this is our work
we're going to deal with weak classes
weak representation classes and we will
try to get strong guarantees strong
security guarantees and we'll call it
the low end regime versus the high-end
regime which appears in the literature
where we have strong program classes
usually General Boolean circuits and we
get weaker weaker weaker guarantees I
forget only computational
so why doing it right like why
asking these questions this type of
questions so
um first the first answer is if if we
want to achieve any notion of
information theoretic security we must
settle for weaker models of computation
right because what I just said we cannot
have
statistical Security in a stronger
models of computation
um in an actual example in these cases
can we often State decision trees right
we can check equivalence of decision
trees quickly so the lower bound that I
just said doesn't work and can we
obfuscate them information theoretic
and another example is that if we want
to orchestrate simple functions
can we obfuscate them in a way that that
preserves the representation so can we
take a 3cnf obfuscate it computationally
but I want the output of the obfuscation
to build three CNS
and of course we can always do high-end
obfuscation we can always run the
algorithms in the literature but the
right question is why to do it right if
you have a decision tree or three CNF
then we really don't want to be
obfuscated by a circuit because it just
adds complexity the representation is
much more complex
um also in practice usually we prefer
simpler representation it appears in the
literature in the learning literature
all the time the distinction between
proper and improper learning algorithm
precisely for those reasons and we ask
why not here of course you could say
interpreter will explainable whatever it
is yeah and we can
yeah
[Music]
but this work is not just about proper
and improper the first step if you want
okay and another good reason is that if
you restrict a good reason not to use
the high end obfuscation is if you
restrict ourselves to weak program
classes we can get stronger guarantees
using simpler algorithms
one example from the literatures with
obds that we can get a much much
stronger
um security guaranteed and computational
instinishability and the algorithm is
much much simpler than the general
obfuscation that appears in the
literature
okay so the high level summary of our
results is first I'm going to show
positive results using white box
learning which is the learning model
that I will Define
it will also prove negative result using
back learning can I get the resultant
proper obfuscation and finally we're
going to separate a few variants of
information theoretic i o and I of
course I will Define them when we get
there but it's important to seal it both
we achieve both negative and positive
results using learning different Notions
of learning of course but using the idea
of learning particularly you are able to
obfuscate things which you don't know
how to learn
so are you able to obfuscate classes
where we don't have a pack learning
algorithm yes so we yeah so this is a
good question this is a good question so
our we will Define the learning model
that is
much more General than the popularity
mode it allows you to do more things so
for now it is open we don't have really
good example but it is plausible that we
can obfuscate things that we cannot
learn basically if you don't have a
separating example like something that
we don't know how to learn but you can
write that you can do you know when we
have things that um
and the usual learning
Paradigm are more complicated and our
part and simplified
okay so first let's talk about the
positive result
is like books learning
so let's start with a warm up if you
have a class can a program a program
class that is exact learnable with
membership queries okay so what does it
mean it means that I have some learn
algorithm we have a learner and it
interacts with some Oracle or someone
who knows the function and membership
queries are simply
queries of the form what is the value of
f of x give me x what is the value given
x what is the value of f of x okay so if
we can if we have an exact learn
algorithm that uses membership queries
and it's an it's an exact algorithm So
eventually the learner knows
specifically exactly what f is it's not
there is no notion of approximation here
and we can efficiently implement the
membership queries
right then in this case it's natural
it's very easy to see why we can
obviously
right and just run the learning
algorithm we'll simulate the membership
queries and since the algorithm yeah
it's only for deterministic algorithms
or
so so okay so
it depends what notion of application
you want
right if your obfuscation is General
application then no the learn algorithm
doesn't have to be determinated so okay
because you're the same distribution
sorry yeah because it's the same
distribution because their in algorithm
only sees semantic properties it only
sees the value of f of x it doesn't say
yes at any point so there's no reason
like to depends
okay but if you look
with more um attention to this paradigm
then well we don't really need
to limit ourselves to membership queries
right all we need is the queries that
are efficiently computable
right from a representation of
of the function and that they only
depend on the semantic of the function
they don't depend on the representation
so this is naturally leads to the
definition of hint functions what is the
hint function for a program class just
just that basically it's an efficiently
computable property of the class that
depends only on the underlying function
and now the yeah can't you get something
stronger like
no because vbb requires you
um to be able to um the obviously
anything in the sense of Black Box okay
and here you do reveal a summer
presentation so essentially it is a
question of how much your the programs
in your program class reveals
right like if I give you a decision tree
for example I can also State well I can
but suppose that we can obfuscate
decision trees in this under this model
right so you you will get a decision
tree and in particular you know a lot
about the function you will know about
the set of ones right because you can
look at the decision you know
suppose even it's a point function but
if it's learnable you could do it by
yourself as well right by just querying
the article and learning the tree by
yourself
yeah but you do have a representation
now now I'm the office table I have a
representation of the class and I give
you an obfuscated program if I give you
a decision tree
so let's suppose it it's a point
function if I give you a decision to
read and obviously you know the point
right but in a vbb model if I give you
an obfuscated version of a point
function you shouldn't know the point
this is somewhat ironic because one of
our motivations in introducing
obfuscation was to try to show that
there are no such properties that
require that can be decided with white
box access that can't be decided with
black boxes
[Music]
okay
so
an example of hint functions let's go
over a few examples of if I have a
decision tree like I think the
conversation just had really explains
this example but if I have a decision
tree then I can Implement equivalence
queries right and equivalence queries
occurs of the form the learner gives the
teacher or Oracle
um
basically learner says I think this is
the function and then the oracleer the
teacher says either yes correct and then
we learned it or or it's or they say no
and if they say no they produce a
counter example there is a point on
which the two models are different
you're if the point they give depends on
the decision tree that they have as you
know not just
53 then you're not necessarily going to
be yes it depends how you implement it
the point is that the learning
algorithms should work regardless of how
you implement the ins so if you have a
learning algorithm that uses
um one hint that depends well it's not
the hint because I defined they need to
be uh
oblivious to the representation but if
you ever learn algorithm that learns
with queries that depends on the
representation yeah right it should work
by the definition because they don't
depend
this is exactly infections so you're
right maybe here I should and
with an equivalence queries it should be
implemented in a way because I believe
it's the decision tree
um and you can do it right like you can
it appears in slides ahead but you can
if I give you a decision tree you can
sample a uniform say it's fine
assignment and you can give me the first
lexicographically satisfying scientific
notes a lot of things
foreign
and this shows why this model of
learning is stronger than the usual
membership equivalent square is right
because this kind of query is given a
uniform satisfying assignment is not
something that you can Implement using
membership or an equivalent squares
so
we are allowing the largest set of
queries in the learning model and so it
is plausible it is money's question
questions that it is possible to have
classes which we can learn in this model
using much more General queries but we
cannot learn under membership for
equivalence queries but for now we're
not uncertain we don't have any concrete
okay so this is our first result theorem
you have a program class Steve and P
admits polynomial time
IO perfect i o right here the notion is
statistical information theoretical
um if and only if we can learn p
you can learn the class using exact
learning algorithm we change functions
and why this is if and only if right
that's
okay and before we go to the proof which
is good
um the obfuscation is proper if enough
if and only if the learning algorithm is
proper in the senses
proper in the learning literature
okay so why why this is true so we can
obfuscate just by running the algorithm
right like I said before and the other
direction is true because we can use IO
as the hint function the definition of
the hint function is General enough to
allow just calling the i o as a hint
so it's it's an infinite and this model
of learning exactly characterizes
information theoretical description
if you have some problem class and you
want to information theoretic obfuscated
it's enough to think about learning
algorithms in this class but in a more
General model of learning
okay so let's see some implications so
before I need to Define what is learning
in the mistake bound models what is
learning the mistake about model we have
a learner that sees the
um the samples in string so they see X1
X2 X3 etc etc and after observing some
sample they need to guess the the
function or the label as they call it in
the learning literature so they need to
predict C of X for some something and
after every mistake they do the learner
makes some mistake after every mistake
they do they can update their uh what
they think the hypothesis is and the
goal is to make at most mistakes on
every order of the samples so the the
order of the samples is possibly
adversarial okay but the goal is still
to make at most mistakes
and it is it has been on for quite a
while but if the concept class can be
learned in the mistake bound model it
can exactly learn using equivalence and
membership queries
so if we can if we have a learning
algorithm in the mistake bound model and
we can Implement equivalence a
membership query efficiently then we can
obfuscate the class right it follows
from what I just said and an application
of this is quasi-polynomial time
canonization algorithm for decision tree
so what we're going to get is um the
algorithm canonizer will Define it uh
some decision trees and this result has
been known or quite recently actually
from 2015 but our Paradigm gives
um a much simpler conceptual way to
derive this result
so the second result is negative result
using pack learning
yeah so where is the mistake found if
there is a mistake bound to M where does
that what does that correspond to me yes
so the mistake bound okay so if you can
learn in the mistake bound model with
the parameter M you can learn you can
exact you can exactly learn using M plus
one equivalence or
um membership queries so this is where
it comes from but then and then when you
obfuscation and
so your obfuscation algorithm will run
we'll make M plus one equivalent
yeah all right
so the second result is negative sorry
before we go here can you just summarize
what you get for decision trees
I don't know if you said it that I
missed it so yeah I can so there is
um
what you get is
um an algorithm that runs in quasi
polynomial time but given any decision
tree
um regardless of its size is the mean of
colonization it gives you a canonical
representation of
a decision tree that computes that
function
so and this implies I'm sorry this is
probably obvious but this implies IO for
decision trees yes so it is a much more
strong guarantee than much stronger idea
right yeah if you canonical the compute
the same time okay yeah so it is a much
stronger could this be done in the
questions
what depth is the tree here
yes so it
um particularly uses a notion of rank
rather than depth
I'm not sure
okay but so I know is there any bound
that you can state in terms of depth of
the tree I mean what's the running time
of this
in terms of the depth of the tree
yeah I'm not sure I mean that depends on
your three I'm not sure what months
has size s then the new one will be like
log squaredness definitely
the time to kind of make canonical
yeah yeah like the output decision tree
will be like s to the log S size but the
depth could be something the the depth
could be a bit worse okay so forget that
so so okay so is this decision so can
you do anything we put it on that size
or or it's unknown or it's like yeah
you mean to do that
so
I think he said that you can you can
colonize
with a quasi polynomial Block in the
size is right yeah yeah and you're
saying it's not known if you can do it
with just a polynomial drop right yeah
and even more more than one even if you
um if you give up the canonization
requirements and only required to um do
some perf yeah statistical perfect
okay sorry since you're saying so much
about it I still didn't catch what
canonization means with
okay so I will say now and then later
we'll
skip this line so
um
if you haven't let's think about perfect
IO so the goal of perfect iOS if you
have two programs of the same side that
could build the same function
you want the distribution
of the i o to be the same on both of
them right okay so now if you have we
can think about notion of a
deterministic IO which is like an IO
deterministic
it's like Maps every two programs of the
same size that are equivalent to the
same thing
okay now we can remove the requirement
of having the same size
so it is a program that Maps every two
equivalents
programs regardless of their size to the
same thing
so it depends on the definition but you
can think about as polynomial in the
input thing
so here is an example for for why it's
not the same thing right like if you
have a program class that has exactly
one circuit of every size
but there's an equivalence in this class
is very difficult
then you have you trivially have
deterministic i o right just like
outputs whatever you get and you're
going to be okay because there is only
one Secret
a given size in this family but you
cannot canonize because you cannot test
equivalence
so it's not yeah so colonization is a
much stronger notion
here would be important right
you know I think it is proper the
mistake about models yeah usually the
alcohol in the import
ant for decision trees no but yeah no
the the application please learnable
model the mistake model doesn't require
both of us right so
um but this is an example I'm pretty
sure that it's a proper learning
okay so now let's get to the negative
result using the learning
okay so now let's talk about three CNN
so equivalents for 3cms is currently
hard so we cannot hope to get
statistical obfuscation
but what about computational proper
obfuscation that is I want the
obfuscater to Output also in 3cm can we
do it
and the answer is no if one-way
functions exists there is no polynomial
time I O computational for three cnfs I
buy three cmaps
and we actually prove something
A Little Bit Stronger
we prove that we cannot obfuscate three
cnfs to any program class whose dual
class is pack learnable
what is the Dual class so a dual class
of a program class just a class of
um
inputs and programs the golf the role of
programs and inputs is being reversed
okay so if we have some function
um eval that evaluates the program p on
an input X right so here on the left
side we have the program Class B right
so we have we have P hard coded or we
remember it and we are ready to perform
evalon any input that we get and the
Dual class is exactly the opposite we
have the input hard-coded we remember
the input and the
um what we get is the program from the
class so this is the Dual class
foreign
class of our program class is particular
build we cannot obfuscate three synapse
into this class so it actually proves a
little bit something a little bit
stronger than obfuscating 3 synapse but
three CNS we cannot obfuscate three cnfs
by any order of one three sentences
of the three synapse to a hundreds it's
impossible
and I like the talk Yesterday by mikito
we know that 3cnfs they are easy to do
allies this is why this theorem is
okay so now let's talk about separating
variants of IO
so we had this discussion with Tony so
I'll just do it quickly uh deterministic
I O is just like an i o when we remove
the probabilistic
option it cannot be probabilistic and
here the industry indistinguishability
is replaced by just
equivalence just the same thing
and the canonizer is a domestic i o so
again we remove the probabilistic and
the indistinguishability but we also
removed the requirements and the size of
the program
and those are not the same and I already
said it before so just stupid
okay so now let's see
um
another separation but in this case
we're going to think about some
obstruction of the model so now we have
an equivalence relation over binary and
bit strings and the way we're going to
think about this relation is the
following two strings are in the
relation if only if they represent the
same program
it's very abstract view about this
stations like we call it outside of
stations okay so what is a canonizer in
this model in this relation so
um given X the canonizer should return
some why the relation with X and
additionally we want that for every X
and yinder relation right the canonizer
of x equals the canonizer five this is
just a definition yeah so to have an
obfuscater you have to be an equivalent
relation
um it just so yeah so we can always
Define this
during the equivalence relation if you
compute the same functions
yeah so yeah so now I just work with
this abstract model of course it's a
weaker right but so we should think of
the relation that we're given this is
the one example but it could be an
arbitrary equivalence relation like
graph isomorphism
yeah okay
um
okay and what is the perfect i o in this
example it's just an algorithm that you
give it a string X and it outputs
equivalent random uniform equivalent
member of the equivalence class
um okay so let's see how to separate
canonization and perfect i o for this
type of relation and we're going to use
a function that has random
self-reduction
so it has been
um mentioned in the workshop before but
I will quickly
just a reminder so what is a random
self-reduction for the function it's
probabilistic polynomial time algorithm
Sigma
input X it outputs a uniform element in
the same with the same answer yes
we
we have examples for such function but
we also need a function that is hard to
check f of x is equal so like Graphics
yeah you can think about it you can also
think about it
um as some sort of encryption
[Music]
yeah but
our ddh encryption right ddh encryption
you can if I give you an encrypted
message you can sample a uniform message
that is the same
um message essentially but you cannot
test if you get to encrypted messages
you're not supposed to be able to tell
if they encrypt the same thing exactly
fits to this
paradigm
okay so in this case like the examples
that we uh just mentioned in this case
we can easily create a relation that has
perfect i o
randomized IO right but which are not
canonized because if we cannot even test
equivalence
yeah and this is the example of the h
and the third theorem is a separation
between
um
perfect I O and deterministic is an
improper i o but it is you can think
about it as in some Oracle model okay so
it is in the common reference ring model
and we assume the existence of a Runway
function ideal prescription
um and again you can think about this
separation as a separation
in in an oracle
okay so now I want to talk about the
Pack Attack with more details
so what is the idea okay what is this
yes so given one-way function and proper
IO for three cnfs we will construct
public encryption where the decryption
surface after the secret key is
hard-coded in it is order one CNF
why this is a problem because order one
cnfs can be packed learned
and that means we can learn the
decryption circuit right and break the
encryption
so we shouldn't be able to to do that
okay so let's build a public encryption
so let's take an injective one-way
function the Assumption the function is
injective can be removed and let's take
a hardcore predicate for the function
and a bit that we want to increase okay
now what is the Hardcore predicate so I
add this and now I've been told that my
doc is no longer relevant because the
deadline passed but the hardcore
predicate is a predicate that we can
efficiently compute given X but we
cannot given f of x
okay so I can just see uh pictorially
what it means
okay so let's describe the public key
encryption
the secret key will be just the random
string and the hardcore predicates
on that screen and the public key will
just be the evaluation of the one-way
function on x
now in order to increase we will create
a circuit
it looks like this but the circuit
computes is
f of x equals the public key and the
hardcore xor m
okay so we can write the program that
computes this function and obfuscate it
so this is the output of the encryption
and in order to decrypt we will just
apply the program that we got right the
message is essentially a program it's
the result of an i o on some program so
we can run
um
this program on our secret key and X
sorry with the hardcore predicate and
why this is true well just run the
program what the program does is
checking if f of x equals f of x which
is true and I can do it because I have
the secret key X and
um
and then there's an n and B which is the
Hardcore predicate which again I know
because I have the secret key xor the
Beats M that I'm trying to encrypt and
then obviously just m
so this is this the encryption is
correct but let's see why this is also
secure
so I have here Delta zero Delta zero is
just the distribution over public land
ciphertext where we encrypt zero
okay Delta one is the same thing except
we encrypt one
and essentially going to prove that
um Delta 0 is computationally
indistinguishable from Delta 1. so in
order to do it I will Define delta 0
Prime and Delta 1 Prime and they're
going to be Delta 0 Prime is just going
to be the encryption of zero but
conditions on the hardcore predicate
being zero
and the claim is that Sigma I'm sorry
Delta 0 and Delta 0 Prime are
computationally indistinguishable just
by the definition of the hardcore
predicate right what's the difference
between Delta 0 and Delta 0 Prime just
the answer potentially the answer of the
hardcore predicate and we shouldn't be
able to tell the difference so there are
computational indistinguishable just by
the definition of a hardcore practical
cut
and
Delta 0 Prime and Delta 1 Prime
those are indistinguishable because of
the obfuscation and why this is true
know that Delta 0 Prime is a
distribution over programs that are or
formulas that are unsatisfiable
right because we encrypt 0 but the
hardcore bit is also zero which means
foreign
those two are equal
so we have an N with a zero so the
entire formula is unsatisfiable in both
cases and both Delta zero Prime and
Delta One Prime
so both of them actually
compute the same function and they're
indistinguishable by the definition of
the obfuscater and what you can see from
this proof is that we don't really need
to assume
i o it is enough to assume that there
exists a weaker notion that only
obfuscates unsatisfiable some of us this
is enough for this proof too to work
does it if you
the general statement of going from IO
to pke
you get a sort of simpler proof
forget the
using this can you get a significance
um
so what do you mean by simpler proof
that's that was kind of simple I I lied
here okay and I will
threatening
light here because
eventually what we want the decryption
circuit to be three CNF and here like
you said it's a general one-way function
no one promises me to be free local
so I essentially lied and you need to
fix it okay and it's not so easy to fix
it because when you do the standard
conversion to 3cnf you're not going to
get a program that is equivalent
it has the same Tuesday but you're just
going to get requested stability and it
adds auxiliary variable and it just
makes the whole thing into a mess so
it's not that but you said that you only
had to be indistinguishable front
satisfiable cases yeah so that
definitely helps so if it's
unsatisfiable then when you add this
stuff it's still unsatisfiable
yeah that yeah but you still need to be
careful when you prove correctness and
security because you add auxiliary
variables and things you just need to be
careful and it's not completely trivial
there is things computation they need to
do but we can do them and it works
it fixes it
okay so now let's talk about some pop-in
problems
so first the natural open problem is
what other representation models admit
the information theoretic i o
so for decision trees for example we
don't know I think yeah it's the next
one we don't know if you have polynomial
time
perfect or statistical information
theoretic i o
uh the third question is can we
obviously Personnel by a zero and here
just a quick comment
basis zero can be learned over the
uniform distribution
but our attack that I just described
creates a weird distribution that we
need to learn on so we crucially rely on
the fact that that we can earn every
distribution in the Pack Attack this is
the definition of the pack learning
right so
learn being able to learn uniform
distribution doesn't mean you can apply
this attack
and even three as a more general
question so what is the minimal
representation classes we can obfuscate
three synapse too right this work tells
us that we cannot do it to any class
whose dual is track learnable but it
doesn't tell us what we can achieve so
this is an interesting
and can we separate between information
theoretic Notions of IO using a natural
program classes or entrepreneur
assumption we called it our separation
using some
um like an oracle money okay let's leave
it like this so can we get it without
any questions
[Applause]
from
Amazon
yeah that's a good question
can you say again what were the
distributions that you have to learn
if you want to learn
well it's not really written here
because I lied about the orchestration
the Republican groups in but you want to
learn the creation
this thing so this is the description
you want to learn these programs after
[Music]
your class
yeah so it's not going to be in for
Institution
negative results uh just to make sure
I'm following two do you need one of my
functions or can you just assume NP is
not in line
the public key encryption personally
relaxing
yeah when we encrypted we use one of the
function but wouldn't like NP not in
like PTP and IO give you this or is give
you one of my functions I guess so yes
the assumption is
um is not in infinitely often Deputy
yeah which is yeah but then I mean yeah
coin in circles if you have one
reflection then if you solve them
okay
thank you so much
foreign